Okay let us do an exercise together.
This time instead of showing that an object is an instance of a cup,
we are going to try to show that an object is an instance of a Mug. So here is
the definition of a Mug. A mug is an object that is stable, enables drinking,
and protects against heat. Notice that we have added one more element here,
not only stable like a cup, not only enables drinking like a cup, but
also protects against heat. Here is an object, I will label in the cushion.
The object is light and is made of clay. It has concavity and has a handle.
The bottom's flat and the sides are thick. You can assume that the agent
knows about all four examples as earlier, the glass, the bowl, the brick, and
the briefcase. [UNKNOWN] in this particular case the agent also knows about yet
another example, a Pot. The Pot carries liquid because it is concave,
It limits heat transfer because it has thick sides and
is made of clay. Your task is to. Build an explanation that shows,
that this object is an instance of a Mug. Can we prove this?